that might be it
did you tell the girls that you guys
know that's true
they know that i'm doing something
because they were like what is that
writing all over you
are you getting another tattoo
[Music]
i actually have my daughter's names
tattooed on my wrist but i felt like
it wasn't enough i've been wanting to
scratch that
itch and so guess what i'm joining
christine today
and we're both getting tattoos right
here
right now and today will be a day that
we will
never forget we are also going to hang
out with
none other than the very first woman
to win inkmaster it's ryan ashley
i've got butterflies i'm very excited
i'm eager i um
i ryan and i already shared our story uh
about what this is gonna mean and um
i've been wanting this for a lot of
years so i'm glad that it's finally
happening
this was not an impulse like what this
was something i've thought about for
many years
drew you're getting a tattoo on
television i am
i'm so excited for you i can't wait to
see what you're getting
i am so excited i came up with this
phrase
and i've been saying it to myself for
the last
five years what is it it's home is where
we are
oh you know if you're somewhere on
vacation
or you're in a rental or you're in
transition
or you have to move from one state to
the next
if you're together that's where home is
i never knew
what home was until i had my daughters
and then i thought oh god
i'm gonna make us a home that will be
forever and so strong
and then life changed and our plans
changed and
we had to move and it all ended up
working out
and it just when i was in rental
apartments or not knowing where
life was going or uncertain or so upset
that the plans i tried to solidify for
my kids
had changed it really actually led to
the discovery of what home
really means for me and that is that
if we are together wherever we are
home is where we are to my daughters if
you ever get to see this episode
you are my home and i love you more than
anything you're the reason
i understand my whole life because of
you so thank you
you are my home
[Music]
you